people inside carrying fire firearms and
wearing
body armor this was no quote summer of
love as the democrat mayor in seattle
said
and president trump compelled action uh
he has said
take back your city now if you don't do
it i will he has said this is not a game
these ugly anarchists must be stopped
immediately move
fast and finally the democrat mayor in
seattle
who was long delayed finally gave the
order to dismantle
the chas and it was an admission it was
an admission that president trump's
vision is right
that anarchy is wrong and that law and
order
bring peace and with that i'll take
questions kristin
thank you so much national security
adviser
robert o'brien said that the
intelligence about the alleged
russia plot was being taken so seriously
that u.s allies
were alerted and that it could impact
military attacking so how is that a hoax
well as i mentioned yesterday uh what
happens when
any intelligence comes in unverified if
there is
any uh way that it could affect american
troops or allies it is immediately
communicated
on the ground to ensure that troops and
commanders and generals can make the
best decisions tactically speaking
so that's the way it's done but what i
would say is at the same time
until there's a strategic decision for
the president to make until it is
verified
it is not briefed up to the president of
the united states that's how
intelligence works
is he angry or frustrated or upset
about the fact that he was not in the
loop on this when members of congress
were briefed and us allies were briefed
no the president
believes that and has great faith in
ambassador o'brien and the others who
made the decision that this shouldn't be
risen to his desk it was a career cia
officer with more than 30 years a tenure
who made the decision not to brief it up
and the national security advisor agreed
with that decision she's an excellent
officer and does great work
um i made the decision not to brief it
up it was the right decision to make and
at this moment as i speak to you it is
still unverified
very quickly i've heard you and robert
o'brien and others express
real outrage about the leaks is there
outrage about what the intelligence
community
is investigating which is the
possibility of these russian bounties
targeting u.s troops
make no mistake uh that this
administration has acted tough on russia
always makes the decision that's in the
best interest of protecting our troops
like killing general
solomoni uh who killed 600 american
troops maimed thousands others and i'll
bag daddy we always act in the best
interest of our troops
um but this is unverified still at this
very moment
john kelly why is the president calling
black lives
matter a symbol of hate well if the
president
um was noting is that uh that symbol
um when you look at some of the things
that have been chanted by black lives
matter like pigs in a blanket fry them
like bacon
um that's not an acceptable phrase to
paint on our streets look he agrees
that all black lives matter including
that of officer david dorn
patrick underwood two officers whose
lives were tragically taken amid these
riots
all black lives do matter he agrees with
that sentiment but what he doesn't agree
with is an organization that chants
pigs in a blanket fry them like bacon
about our police officers our valiant
heroes who are out on the street
protecting us each and every day
americans of all races have protested in
all 50 states
uh around that phrase black lives matter
and the president is here calling it a
symbol of hate he's talking about the
organization
i would note to you that the greater new
york blm
president has said if this country
doesn't give us what we want
that we will burn down the system and i
could be speaking literally i'd call
that a pretty hateful statement
yes organization in his tweet he says
yes he says the words
what's the name of the organization
again black lives matter there you go
you just answered my question
go ahead earlier today the president
said i think that at some point that's
going to sort of just disappear i hope
he's hoping that it will disappear the
president's strategy at this point
no the president's confident that it'll
disappear he's confident that he's put
together
a revolutionary first-class
team that is going to break through
bureaucracy and get us a vaccine
he's confident that that will lead us to
a place where we won't have
uh covet on our hands and in fact there
was very pleasing news today from pfizer
and
in tech that showed positive results for
their vaccines
dr valkyrie says that we're heading
towards 100 000 cases per day
but so why does the president have
evidence that it would just disappear
one thing i wouldn't know um with regard
to cases we're aware that there are
embers in the country we're aware that
there are places with rising cases and
that's why dr burks is on the ground and
others we're continually assessing that
but
one thing i would note is just that when
you do test more people you do identify
more cases and that is rapidly ongoing
we're testing
more than a half a million a day to give
you an example on april 6
really the height of the pandemic we
were doing 151
525 tests one day you know thursday is
the number
that i have here we conducted 637 587
tests so when you have more than a
five-fold increase in test
you have a greater identification of
cases consider what's happening in
florida in texas
arizona has embers i would say that
those are we see rising cases we see
embers around the country we always knew
that would come with reopening but
uh those who are identifying as positive
cases do tend to be younger
individuals as the vice president noted
and i think the increase in testing is
part of
the contribution to what we're seeing
yes um today mayor bowser
said uh her office is communicating with
the department of interior about the
fourth of july celebration
and it's not in her mind in keeping with
cdc guidelines
as well as dc department of health
guidelines
the white house has said over and over
again we should look to our local
authorities for how we should act should
the what should should the
administration be following the local
guidelines
president said that um we should follow
our local authorities with mass so
that's the decision
uh that he encourages people to follow
those authorities um the cdc guidelines
i'd also note say recommended but not
required
um and we are very much looking forward
to the fourth of july
celebration yes are you preparing some
options for the president to consider
for retaliation against russia should
this intelligence
prove to be true and i won't get ahead
of the president on action i also won't
get ahead of the intelligence which at
this moment is unverified
does it want this intelligence to be
corroborated or not or
i mean what has he told his advisors on
this front um the president is
unverified it's being assessed it's
going through the same process
normal intelligence would go through but
what's unfortunate is we're having this
discussion because
um of the new york times deciding to run
with this
and erroneous information about the
president being briefed which was not
true and the erroneous information that
there was a conclusion when in fact
there was not a conclusion jen yes
kaylee can you confirm
that the cia director and the nsa
director will brief the congressional
gang of eight
tomorrow about the russia boundaries yes
that is the plan
two of them anyone else that will be
reaping uh i'm not entirely sure who
else will be uh in that briefing
does the president generally have
confidence in the intelligence
community's
findings and conclusions about russia
yes he does have
confidence and he's many times acted um
on verified intelligence and um there's
times he's decided
that it's in our strategic interests not
to act i'd give you the example of
solomoni and al-baghdadi and then the
example of
iran shooting down um
when iran engaged in actions and the
president said it's not time
uh to engage because um shooting down um
a shooting down an entity is not the
same as losing loss of civilian lives
yes thank you shooting down at your own
excuse me yes
the president will come under criticism
this week for statements that he has
made
that his detractors say are dog whistles
to a certain segment of his face
that he is trying to generate for
reelection those include comments like
kung flu our heritage while talking
about confederate statues
and most recently they include the video
that i know you discussed on her the
other day
but the video of a supporter of his uh
using the term white power
so why hasn't the president denounced
that video and called that a hateful
statement
the president took down that video um
that deletion speaks strongly in what i
would note the president has
repeatedly condemned hate august of 2019
and one voice our nation must condemn
racism
bigotry and white supremacy these
sinister ideologies must be defeated
hate has no place in america in april
2019 we have no tolerance
for those who disrupt this peace and we
condemn all hate and violence especially
in our places of worship
august 2018 i condemn all types of
racism he's repeatedly done this
i haven't even announced that specific
video and said that that is
hateful language that was used in it he
deleted it the deletion speaks for
itself his repeated condemnations of
hate speak for themselves and
this is a president who's repeatedly
condemned hate and repeatedly encouraged
for us all to come together yes thank
you
did the president meet today with senate
republican leader mcconnell
about the future recovery aid package
and is there any sort of agreement on
additional unemployment insurance or
stimulus payments
yeah so i have no announcements with
regard to his meetings but what i would
say is he did
mention that in a phase four he would be
open to direct payments
on the point of unemployment insurance
one thing that he's concerned about is
he does not want to see
an incentive not to work and enhanced
unemployment
benefits that senator schumer has
suggested would be an incentive for
people not to get back to work and he
wants to encourage
people to get back to work and at the
same time he's mentioned a payroll tax
holiday a
big win for our workers that helps those
who are on the lowest end of the payroll
would help the americans who need it
most so those are some things he's
talked about
for phase four hey you used the word
embers to describe the chronovirus but
yesterday another all-time record of 47
000
cases and four times this week a new
record
why do you use the word embers when many
people would say it's more like a
wildfire
so i use the word embers because that is
what the president has acknowledged that
would happen around the country you
would see
spikes across the country uh he said at
times you would see a fire across the
country embers
fires but at the same time i would note
the increase in cases
uh that are the increase in testing you
know six-fold increase in testing you
identify more cases i'd also note
uh that secretary azar said that we've
seen nationwide that fatalities at a
two-month low
so this is a different situation when
those who are testing positive are
younger
uh we have increased tests we're aware
where there are where there are surges
that's why dr burks is on the ground but
we believe we are equipped to handle
what we see on the horizon
as the president made a conscious
decision to talk less about the virus
you know i think in his
temple with sean hannity someone
mentioned it was only three minutes and
he discussed it he
he tweets about it far less often than
he used to the president is not focused
on talking he's focused on action and
his administration has taken historic
action with regard to the coronavirus we
have an
excess amount of ppe surge a huge amount
of ventilators in the stockpile things
that could never be done
we were told have been done under this
administration testing
more than six hundred thousand a day uh
this president has done a historic job
with regards to the coronavirus
thank you president yesterday tweeted
that he's angry against china
there's anger against china and india
also so india has banned 59
apps from china including tick tock uh
how
how does the president was about it and
what are his views on this
so with regard to india and china um
we're closely monitoring the situation
he is as well both india and china have
expressed a desire to de-escalate and we
support a peaceful
resolution of the current situation and
he said that china's
aggressive stance along the india-china
border fits with a larger pattern of
chinese aggression
in other parts of the world and these
actions only confirm the true nature of
the chinese communist party
india banning the tick tock app no
announcements on that i would just point
you to what secretary pompeo said
earlier
yeah would we expect the president to
weigh
in on israel's plan to annex parts of
the west bank
and the jordan valley and how much does
this delay
perhaps have to do with the concern
about setting evangelists here in the
united states you're
of course a really important part of the
president's face of the election
yeah so i've not spoken to him about
that specific issue um but he's a great
supporter of israel and i would just
leave it at that
there could be something that's weak so
i'm just wondering what the delay is
and maybe you could weigh in on you know
there are concerns this could be the
final
nail in the coffin on a palestinian
state like what is the president
thinking about so no announcements on
that front and i won't get ahead of him
on anything that would happen this week
or beyond
yes and the president has said in this
room that he wants to meet the taliban
leadership
now that um world leaders are coming
here again is that on the cards is that
going to happen soon is there a time
table
so again i won't get ahead of the
president on that what the president
wants is to see
our troops come home from afghanistan he
has been on the record
being against keeping a sustained
presence in afghanistan
he does not believe in foreign
adventurism and
wars that drag on he believes the
ultimate way to secure our troops is to
bring them home
the russian bounties to taliban fighters
affected that capitalism that's
unverified intelligence
that's currently being assessed yamiche
i think
the first question i have two questions
the first is on monday the president
went after
stripping racist names on buildings on
tuesday
he went after a rule to combat racial
segregation and then today he
said that he described the words black
lives matter as a symbol of hate
why is he digging in on race in this way
so first i mean if you're
saying that the fact that he does not
want to rename
um our bases um if you're considering
that racist then apparently
56 of america is as well because 56
percent of america is against changing
the name
of u.s military bases um he believes
that
our young men and women who left these
bases overseas many of whom lost their
lives
and the last thing they saw was being on
one of these military bases
that they should not be told that the
base that they they trained in
the last place they saw on american soil
was a racist institution and that's a
proposition
the vast majority of america agrees with
including him saying that the words
black lives matter as
we've noted has been chanted in 50
states why is he saying that that's a
symbol of hate uh
on top of all the other things that he's
done just this week alone in terms of
race
well is pigs in a blanket frying like
like bacon racist i mean
is that is that hateful that is a
hateful thing to say i would argue i
i would think the vast majority of
america would agree with that too i
think the vast majority of america
would think it's hateful uh to say that
we will burn down the system and i could
be speaking literally i think the vast
majority of america would agree
with him yet again that holding up a
severed pig's head
uh is unacceptable he you're not going
to do that i have a second question
i did engage on that that's the second
question i engaged on that yamiche and i
said we agree
all black lives matter with that
sentiment but we will not stand with an
organization
that exhibits that kind of hate against
our police officers
what does the president have to say to
military service the families of
service members who are really afraid
that their loved ones might have been
killed in connection to this frontier
to this russia bounty their families
already saying we want the united states
to
in federal government to call us and
settle us up kristin had an interview
with
with the father saying that just this
week what is this president's message to
the military famous
in this country so that it's unverified
intelligence it's continually being
assessed and the department of defense
has said
they do not know of any americans that
have been killed in relation to this
unverified intelligence that's currently
being assessed
thank you the president has stated in
past that he will not
tolerate defunding police and he said
this multiple times
considering that many democrat-led
cities have now done so including new
york city as of this morning
what does not tolerating this move look
like from the president's advantage
at this time yeah i mean speaking out
fervently against it um and what it
means is you know this executive order
gives additional funding to police
departments if they meet certain
standards we want
safe policing we want to make sure that
police officers are trained to
de-escalate
that's why there is this supplementary
funding in the e.a.o that incentivizes
and
rewards police departments that train
their officers in de-escalation
uh that get rid of choke holds except
when uh there's an incident of lethal
force but
look he stands firmly with america yet
again on this with 64 percent of
opposing defunding the police that's a
huge number 57
and according to another huffpo you gov
poll stand against it and
um look they where america stands is
here where
we're at a place where 64 of the nation
are concerned that the growing criticism
of america's police
will lead to a shortage of police
officers that will harm all americans
it's an untenable principle and it's
unacceptable when you have people like
representative ocasio-cortez really
suggesting where the democrat party
stands today because taking a billion
away from nypd
police officers wasn't enough for her
she wants to take it all away she
doesn't want police officers um and
that's a really unacceptable proposition
on the usmca also it takes effect at
midnight what immediate changes is the
white house hoping to
see immediately starting tomorrow and
then are there any elements of the usmca
that may be
hindered because of kobe 19. now the
usmca
today that goes into effect it's a huge
deal for years
or decades uh nafta wreaked havoc on
american society
closing uh our factories hemorrhaging
amen
american manufacturing jobs and the
usmca is a massive
win it will create 176 000 jobs
um add 68 billion dollars to the u.s
economy
uh 28 000 manufacturing jobs are
expected to be added
and agricultural agricultural and food
exports will increase by 2.2 billion a
big win for our farmer
farmers so we expect to see that start
to take effect
and it's a big deal and it's a reversal
of decades of fail us policy with the
usmca
the trans-pacific partnership um
horrible trade deals that betrayed
america's workers
under president trump the forgotten man
and woman is forgotten no longer
thank you guys
how are you how you guys doing
oh really oh really